tout de suite l'do de Patrick
Cohen alors Patrick vous hésité en tout
cas sur le titre du film qui convient
aux tentatives de sauvetage du projet
sur l'immigration il y a deux solutions
petit arrangement entre amis ou massacre
à laçonneuse voilà alors rappelons
d'abord les données de base le projet
d'armanin qui se voulait gentil avec les
gentils les travailleurs et méchant avec
les méchants les délinquants a été
rejeté sans débat à l'Assemblée par la
droite et le Renn qui trouvait la loi
trop gentille et par la gauche qui la
jugait trop méchante l'exécutif s'en
remet à une gentille CMP commission
mixte paritaire avec se députés 7
sénateurs mais pas plus de majorité qu'à
l'Assemblée puisque sa composition
reflète celle des deux chambres il y
aura donc cinq macronistes quatre LR
deux socialistes un centriste un
insoumis un RN on va enfermer tous ce
beau monde lundi à 17h à H8 clos sans
représentant du gouvernement avec pour
mission de bâtir un texte de compromis à
minimum donc au minimum à 8 contre 6
donc forcément quand on voit les
chiffres forcément sur la base d'un
accord entre droite et majorité
présidentielle s'ils y arrive hop le
texte sera soumis dès le lendemain au
vote de l'Assemblée et du Sénat vote
sans débat emballé c'est pesé l'affaire
seraplié dès mardi soir 19 décembre Noël
avec 6 jours d'avance c'est aussi simple
que ça non c'est pas simple du tout et
c'est justement parce que ça n'a rien de
simple que le gouvernement négocie
depuis hier en direct avec les chefs LR
Eric cotti Bruno taillot Olivier marlex
àamatignon dans le bureau d'éliisabeth
borne en présence de Gérald armanin en
tout cas il était hier pour tenter des
petits arrangements entre amis amis à
qui la première ministre a cru faire
plaisir en sortant la tronçonneuse pour
massacrer la loi non disons pour la
tronçonner ou pour la saucissonner pour
ne garder que le volet fermeté du projet
les mesures qui facilitent l'expulsion
des étrangers délinquants donc la partie
méchante en renvoyant au Caland ou un
autre projet les dispositions les plus
clivantes dont la partie la plus
gentille sur la régularisation des
sans-papiers dans les métiers en tension
refus des sénateurs Alair qui exige un
compromis au plus près du texte qu'ils
ont voté au Sénat et ne veulent pas que
le gouvernement il fasse son marché
comme il l'entend 2h30 de réunion pour
rien rebelote ce matin même lieu même
participant même objet sans plus de
résultat ellisabeth borne vient d'en
informer ses principaux ministre avant
de se rendre à l'Assemblée nationale ce
soir pour échanger avec sa majorité des
députés chronistes qui de leur côté ont
défini leurs propres exigences maintien
de l'aide médicale d'État pas de
restriction au droit du sol pas de
placement rétention des mineurs
étrangers de moins de 16 ans et
maintient des possibilités de
régularisation enfin à peu près tout le
contraire de ce que veut la droite on a
rangé la tronçonneuse mais il n'y a ni
arrangement ni amis dans cet épisode
extravagant pourquoi extravagant une loi
ça se discute et ça s'élabore en public
au grand jour le Parlement est fait pour
ça pas dans des antichambres
ministérielles il est fascinant de voir
ceux qui ont refuser lundi le débat à
l'Assemblée 15 jours de discussion étit
prévu après avoir déserté les rencontres
de Saint-Denis avec Emmanuel Macron se
prêter à des marchandages dans le secret
des palais officiels avec une importance
politique et un appelon oratoire sans
commune mesure avec leur poids électoral
la droite LR c'est rappelons-le 4,7 %
des voix à la dernière présidentielle
avec Valérie pécrè 11 % aux législatives
et un groupe qui ne fait même pas bloc
derrière les positions intransisante de
leur chef puisqu'il n'y a eu lundi que
40 députés LR sur 62 pour voter la
motion de Roget l'exécutif s'en remet
donc à un parti sans cap ni boussol mais
qui s'affiche désormais sur
l'immigration avec un programme
similaire à celui du rassemblement
national quel que soit le sort de cette
loi
immigration sort sans doute pas très
favorable quand même les palinodies
politiques qui l'accompagne resteront
risque de rester aussi désastreuses dans
l'opinion que l'usage du 493 un épisode
extravagant des autrement dit des
retournements de veste du marchandage
dans le secret à l'abri de regard des
postures du cynisme le tableau est
effectivement désastreux c'est le
constat que vous faites aussi François
c'est extrêmement juste il s'est passé
quelque chose à
quoi me semble-t-il on n pas fait assez
attention et qui est historique au sens
propre du terme parce que c'est sans
aucun
précédent l'Assemblée nationale a refusé
à annuler le rôle législatif qui est le
sien sur un texte présenté par tout le
monde les pour et les contre comme un
texte essentiel et elle a dit B on va
pas elle a dit l'opposition on
s'applaudit enfin en applaudissant cette
motionet appant les alr n'ont pas
applaudi enfin c'était le Ren et la
gauche qui oui voilà mais il y a eu
beaucoup
d'applaudissements un sentiment de
victoire totalement déplacé parce que de
ça il va évidemment rester des
conséquences très importantes c'est que
le texte qui va être examiné c'est le
texte du Sénat et que l'Assemblée
nationale élu pour écrire et discuter la
loi décide que
sur un texte des principes sur
lesquelles on s'est écharpé on on n'en
parlerait pas on se tiendrait à l'écart
à mon sens
c'est complètement déplacé et même pas
loin d'être délirant est-ce que
l'opposition est la seule responsable de
cette situation je
je il y a il y a plein de responsables
partout dans le style dans la manière
dans les com au gouvernement sans doute
dans les dans les attitudes dans les
dans bon mais si des députés refusent de
voter la loi à quoi bon être élu député
hmm et et et tout ça participe vous
voyez bien à un mouvement qui est lancé
depuis longtemps ou en tout cas quelques
mois euh les aboiements à l'Assemblée
nationale les insultes réciproques les
cette espèce de caricature de de à la
fois cours de récréation et ring de box
euh est complètement déplacé et je crois
complètement éloigné de ce que les
électeurs les citoyens voudraient
d'une assemblée comme celle-là il y a
des positions extrêmement tranchées H
desclivages qui dans l'opinion n'existe
pas à ce point ou n'existe pas de cette
manière parce que l'opinion était
favorable au texte projet de loi sur
l'immigration on voit bien ce qu'ils
veulent en tout cas si je le traduis et
probablement il y a un peu de de ce que
je préférerais dans dans ce que je vais
dire si je le traduis c'est assez
simple les Français veulent
qu'il y ait de la rigueur et même de la
sévérité quand il y a des dérapages et
des dérives de la part de personnes
immigrées et en même temps en tout cas
c'est comme ça moi que je le ressens
dans mon pays je suis élu dans les
Pyrénées on lorsqu'il y a des personnes
qui nous ont
rejoint chassé par beaucoup de misère et
de violence parfois euh qui sont chez
nous qui
travaillent qui veulent parler français
qui parlent français ou qui apprennent
le français et qui comprennent que notre
pays n'est pas une page blanche sur
laquelle on peut écrire n'importe quoi
que nous avons des principes des modes
de vie euh et je je pense par exemple à
à la laïcité que chez nous c'est pas la
religion qui fait la loi d'où
l'importance protège la religion de la
jambe gauche de ce projet loi
d'immigration sur la régularisation je
déteste je
déest l'idée qu'il y a des jambes
gauches et des jambes droites dans la
politique parce que ou alors c'est des
ou alors c'est des Mille Pattes hein
parce que parce que parce qu'il y a il y
a une multitude de tout ce qui s'est
passé ces derni jour le prouve au
contraire François Baayou c'est le
réveil précisément du clivage gauche-
droite et de l'impossibilité de faire
marcher les choses en même temps patri
Cohen je suis assez souvent d'accord
avec vous même très souvent d'accord
avec vous il y a pas la TR du
cvageite et sur cette affaire non il y a
la trace d'un désordre dans les esprits
qui fait que les oppositions entre
guillemets ont
choisi de
de de se supprimer elle-même de
s'effacer
elle-même au lieu de se faire arquir
comme
législateur au lieu
d'examiner les questions les éventuels
changements les amendements c'est ça un
texte euh et et
si vous avez au moins trois gauches
peut-être quatre gauche absolument
inconciliable comme on le voit tous les
jours et à droite c'est semble-t-il la
même chose donc ce qu'on appelait gauche
alors j'accepte que vous disiez que je
suis quelqu'un du centre éternellement
et que et que je pense que c'est que
c'est là qui est une des clés de
l'avenir la capacité a considéré qu'on
peut faire se parler ensemble des gens
qui partent d'un désaccord qui regardent
la situation et qui disent on peut pas
en rester là c'est précisément là que
que que repose ou que réside la clé de
l'avenir vous l'avez dit le risque là
c'est que le texte qui soit
éventuellement adopté ce soit celui
qu'avait voté le Sénat alors est-ce que
non ça sera pas celui qui a voté le
Sénat il s'en rapprochera c'est ce que
vous avez dit c'est le risque est-ce
qu'éliizabeth borne et Géral mtenant
dans ce cas on raison de s'entêter
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment tenter de
sauver cette loi coûte que coûte qui
perdre son âme qui a il perdent
l'essence de cette loi qui était au
départ vous semblitil équilibré oui qui
était équilibré ça n'est pas si
simple on a un parlement qui n'a pas de
majorité absolue et à vu humaines et
pendant longtemps ça va durer comme ça
et je préféreraai moi qu'il y ait une
loi proportionnelle qui fasse que chacun
soit assuré d'avoir sa part
représentative des sièges à la mesure
des voies qu'on représente dans
l'opinion et ça serait un pluralisme
organisé et on apprendrait à travailler
ensemble mais le le président de la
République est le gardien des
institutions tous les présidents de la
République successifs c'est leur c'est
leur métier de garder les institutions
on a un processus parlementaire et le
texte est pas allé au Parlement au bout
de la discussion au Parlement on peut
regarder s'il y a une possibilité après
on votera pour moi c'est un gâchier
épouvantable parce que
si un texte est conclu par la commission
mix paritaire ce groupe d'entente entre
des sénateurs et des députés pour voir
si on peut trouver si un texte est
conclu et s'il est voté il sera voté
sans avoir jamais été examiné c'est
c'est Patrick en l'a dit c'est dingue on
est on est dans euh comment vous pouriez
définir ça ils se sont fait élire pour
ça et donc bon le l'esprit
partisan l'a emporté sur le minimum de
conscience du
devoir de cette mission de représent
l'argument c'était si le texte était
battu et qu'au final le gouvernement
dégane le 493 il y aura eu un débat mais
on sera imposé quand même un projet de
loi par le gouvernement j'ai toujours
été opposé au 493 sur un texte de cet
ordre je vous dis le principe que j'ai
défendu et que je continuerai à défendre
parce que je le crois juste c'est il y a
deux sortes de textes il y a les textes
vitaux sans lesquels vous ne pouvez pas
exercer la fonction de
gouvernement par exemple le budget vous
ne pouvez pas gouverner sans avoir de
budget donc si le budget est menacé de
ne pas être adopté alors vous mettez
votre existence en jeu donc cela c'est
justifié de faire les 493 oui il y a des
gens qui disent que que le 493 n'est pas
démocratique c'est le sommum des
institutions de la 5e République on dit
vous considérez qu'un texte est
essentiel s'il est essentiel vous mettez
votre existence en jeu et puis il y a
les les autres textes qui sont les
textes que j'appelle
utiles euh sur des sujets très
importants les textes utiles c'est des
textes dans lesquels on propose une
orientation au Parlement cette
orientation est discutée et débatue si
elle est acceptée vous avez une nouvelle
règle une nouvelle norme si elle ne
l'est pas et bien vous remettez euh vous
remettez sur le métier euh l'ouvrage bon
il y a rien de plus simple que ça et il
faut apprendre à vivre à avec cette
cette vision là et puis deux chambres
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat à
condition que les deux jouent leur rôle
h
euh des des députés qui vous le dites se
font arakiri on pense que ça va
augmenter un peu plus la défiance des
Français à l'égard du monde politique
les Français qui vut aussi certain de
leurs responsables politiqu devoir
répondre à la justice ça a été le cas
d'Éric Dupont moréti face à la cour de
la Justice de la République Olivier
dusopte en ce moment face au tribunal
correctionnel de Paris et vous-même
puisque pendant 5 semaines vous avez
comparu devant le tribunal de Paris au
côté presque 6 au côté de 10 anciens
cadres élu centrist pour les soupçons de
détournement de fonds public dans
l'affaire des assistants parlementaires
européens vos avocats ont pladé la
relaxe l'accusation a réclamé 30 mois
d'emprisonnement avec surc 70000 €
d'amende et 3 ans d'inégiliibilité avec
surcis jugement en attente pour le 5
février vous attendez ce jugement avec
appréhension sérénité bon ce ce sont des
épisodes je vais pas vous cacher ça
violent vous vous vous vivez là quelque
chose que vous n'auriez jamais cru
devoir vivre euh mais
euh au moins avons-nous pu pour la
première fois dans cette affaire faire
entendre euh non pas des arguments
seulement
mais apporter des faits et en effet j'ai
vécu ça d'abord avec ce malaise là mais
en même temps avec le
sentiment que pour une fois
euh nous nous avions pu tous ensemble
montrer non pas notre vérité mais la
réalité des choses alors on verra d'ici
au 5 février le 5 février ce qu'il en a
été mais je je vous avez été blessé par
cet épisode en juin 2017 c'est dès
l'ouverture de l'enquête préliminaire
que vous avez démissionné vous avez dû
quitter vos fonctions de garde des saut
un mois seulement après votre nomination
éc Dupont je n'ai pas dû j'ai choisi
vous avez choisi reti lui il a choisi en
tout cas il a pu rester à son poste
malgré sa mise en examen et durant toute
la durée de son procès et il a continué
à exercer au nom de la présomption
d'innocence est-ce que vous trouvez ça
cohérent ce qui valait pour François
beirou ne vaut pas pour je sais que ça a
beaucoup été écrit mais je suis obligé
de dire que la situation est pas du tout
la même pour deux raisons la première
c'est que dans notre
cas personne ne m'a demandé de quitter
cette fonction au contraire le président
de la République et je rappelle j'étais
pas mis en examen il y avait CIT
l'ouverture d'une enquête préliminaire
VO et c'est moi qui ai choisi nous avons
choisi en particulier Marielle de Sarnez
qui n'est plus là et moi nous avons
choisi de quitter le gouvernement
pourquoi j'ai passé les 20 dernières
années de l'action politique notamment
dans des campagnes présidentielles à
défendre l'idée d'une moralisation de la
vie publique vous défendez l'idée de la
moralisation vous êtes garde des saau
ministre de la Justice
et il y a contre vous de manière à mes
yeux totalement injuste
déclenchement d'une enquête préliminaire
ce qui veut dire après de de monter des
des des enquêtes des soupçons et puis
mise en examen j'ai considéré moi
d'accord qui était un homme politique
c'était pas le cas d'éc du pomp Moretti
j'ai considéré moi qu'il n'y avait
aucune possibilité de exercit
sereinement la fonction qui était la
mienne et je l'avais dit au président de
la République très tôt et j'ai décidé de
ne plus participer au gouvernement à la
suite des eurodéputés modem
euh marine le le rassemblement national
pardon Marine Le Pen son père et 26
personnes de leur parti seront aussi
jugées à l'automne prochain pour
détournement de fond dans euh ce qui
apparaît comme étant
[Musique]
le même délit la même chose est-ce que
vous ditesv que c'est le même reproche
qui est fait aujourd'hui rassemblement
national comodem et est-ce que les
affaires sont strictement comparables et
reproche oui même dossier non sans aucun
doute je ne connais pas le dossier du
Front National et on aura tout à fait
l'occasion de regarder ça parce
que assistant parlementaire vous avez
dit le thème de l'accusation c'est
détournement de F fond public il y a
jamais eu de détournement il y a jamais
eu de fond public le il est il est écrit
10 fois dans notre dossier qui a jamais
eu d'enrichissement personnel et qui n'y
a jamais eu d'emploi fictif oui n c'est
quand même des fonds publics non c'est
ceci est autre est autre chose mais je
veux évidemment pas parler de d'une
autre affaire donc il sera temps de
parler de cette affaire le le jour venu
ce que je sais moi c'est que le la
situation dans laquelle nous étions nous
avons pu je crois prouver que
elle était sans aucun élément qui puisse
appuyer je puis vous le dire pour mon
cas l'accusation telle qu'elle était
formulée et que nous n'avions jamais en
7 ans eu
l'occasion de faire entendre ses
arguments et d'apporter des éléments de
preuve ce qui est extraordinaire mais
c'est c'est c'est comme ça la vie et
puis on est des justiciables comme les
autres donc on va vivre c'est une
expérience intéressante
euh pas agréable mais intéressante
d'avoir vécu euh 6 semaines de
procès sur une accusation dont vous
pensez avec toutes vos fibres qu'elle
n'est pas fondée d' en deux mots vous
c'est vous vous avez plaidé le le fait
que les assistants travaillaient
effectivement pour les eurodéputés et
pas pour le parti et vous ne savez pas
si c'est la même chose pour le
rassemblement national ce je je lis les
articles comme tout le monde je vais pas
apparaître comme laabich et faroucher
c'est pas c'est pas du tout mon cas je
pense que que cette question là de de
l'engagement des responsables politiques
et des députés est une question qui
mérite d'être traitée mais dans notre
cas à nous ça n'était pas le ça n'était
pas vrai depuis le début du enfin je le
crois et je veux pas préjuger depuis le
début du conflit entre Israël et le
Hamas les Atta les actes antisémites ont
triplé en France mardi un homme s'est
introduit dans une crèche à champignny
sur Marne dans Val de Marne il a menacé
la directrice d'un couteau il a aussi
proféré des injures antisémites là il
est toujours en fuite c'est un nouvel
exemple des tensions qui existent en
France comment est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour les
apaiser euh ce sont des tensions qui
existent dans le dans le monde pas
seulement en France c'est en France que
nous avons l'écho de tension qui existe
dans le monde qui existe depuis
longtemps qui remonte aussi très loin
dans l'histoire comment on peut les
apaiser
un il y a un travail
d'éducation y compris par les médias
c'est pas c'est pas seulement les
éducateurs professionnels qui doivent
la mission d'éducation civique tout le
monde doit le faire deuxièmement je
pense que moi je pense qu'il faut se
garder d'exacerber les les conflits de
de de de jeter de de l'huile
perpétuellement sur le
feu pour une raison profonde qui att
trait au premier sujet qu'on a traité
tout à l'heure de
l'immigration c'est que nous devons nous
devrons et nous devons vivre ensemble
c'est ce qui est fait jeter de l'huile
sur le feu vous pensez si vous lisez les
réseaux sociaux je vous garantis qu'il y
a pas mal d'huile sur pas mal de foyers
oui de responsables politiques qui
jettent de l'huile sur le feu ah
sûrement toujours il y a y a il y a il y
a cette idée qu'on gagne plus de voix en
opposant les gens les uns aux autres
qu'en essayant de les rassembler pour
les faire travailler ensemble si vous
regardez la situation des
États-Unis et Trump en particulier mais
il y a eu des exemples en France
naturellement du même ordre l'idée que
c'est plus attractif pour les partisans
les esprits partisans et les esprits
sectaires de désigner un ennemi de le
vouer à la vindicte populaire c'est
beaucoup plus attractif que d'essayer de
comprendre sa part de vérité et
cependant notre responsabilité alors je
dis notre au sens le plus G du terme
mais des hommes politiques en
particulier en tout cas ceux qui croient
à cette mission notre responsabilité
c'est pourtant
d'essayer d'aller dans le sens d'une
meilleure compréhension
[Musique]
réciproque peut-être ce sont de bons
sentiments mais je crois que c'est des
sentiments sans lesquels nous ne pouvons
pas vivre et je pense qu'on l'oublie
trop parce que le la la fascination
des sondages ou des intentions de vote
est très puissante et il faut avoir pas
mal de caractère pour y résister
François verou le président de la
République a dit vouloir prendre une
initiative dès le début du mois de
janvier prochain pour lancer au pays un
message justement d'unité vous avez une
suggestion un conseil à lui donner sur
la manière d' j'avais un conseil à lui
donner je le lui donnerai
personnilà il faudra pas que des mots
ben
je dire ce que je crois vraiment pas le
président de la République mais moi je
pense que notre
pays depuis des années est dans
l'attente de quelque chosees qui
permettent d'imaginer autrement que dans
le conflit perpétuel
caricatural le le l'ffront la la vie
démocratique pour moi la vie
démocratique c'est pas que le conflit et
c'est précisé cette recherche là de
reconnaissance des grands courants des
grandes philosophie et de leur
possibilité de vivre
ensemble pendant très longtemps j'ai cru
que j'ai cru comme tout le monde que la
politique ça consistait à faire
triompher ses idées sur celles des
autres j'ai cru
ça comme tout le monde je trouvais mes
idées assez bonnes euh je continue
d'ailleurs à les trouver assez bonnes je
trouvais mes idées assez bonnes et je
trouvais que les victoires électorales
devaient permettre de les imposer et
avec le temps je suis allé vers une
autre vision la politique ça consiste à
pouvoir faire vivre ensemble des idées
différentes et que vos idées soient
prises en compte dans le débat général
pris en compte pas écraser les autres ce
que je crois pas une seconde avec euh l'
expérience qui est la mienne de ce de ce
secteur de la vie d'un pays je ne crois
pas une seconde que ça
existe d'imposer ces idées au point
d'écraser les autres simplement on peut
quand on est au pouvoir on a l'illusion
qu'on peut faire ça et ça ne marche
jamais il faut aussi être capable
d'entendre ce que vos concurrents
adversaires
complémentaires disent et pensent et
leur manière d'être bah si ça s'adresse
pas au Président je sais pas à qui ça
s'adresse parce là c'est pile c'est pile
pour Emmanuel macronenez dire je pense
je vais vous dire ça va vous surprendre
je pense qu'il pense ce que je pense ah
oui mais mais il en prend pas il en
prend pas des
conséquences je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous pour dire
que l'organisation du pouvoir et de la
vie publique ne va pas dans ce
sens-l l'organisation du pouvoir et de
la vie publique je vais vous dire ce que
c'est
c'est j'entre au
gouvernement il faut absolument que je
prouve que mes prédécesseurs sont des
incapables que mais vraiment nul comme
ils sont comme ils ont été c'est pas
possible et que
deuxièmement vous allez changer
définitivement le réalité la réalité
j'ai été comme ça comme tout le
monde à une nuance près j'avais dit dans
ma mission d'éducation sur l'éducation
nationale j'avais dit que je ne feraiis
pas de loi qui porterai mon nom h parce
que je je je je pense que la la vraie
méthode c'est la
sédimentation vous prenez en compte euh
ce qui est arrivé les décisions qui ont
été prises et puis vous essayez de leur
donner une orientation et concrètement
ça donnerait quoi si Emmanuel Macron il
il suivait votre exemple là au 1er
janvier qu'est-ce qu'il doit faire quel
est le le geste symbolique en en un
exemple court qui prouverait qu'il a
compris non je je si il y a il y a une
chose évidente pour moi c'est le
changement de la loi électorale c'est
la c'est la première chose tous les pays
d'Europe sans
exception tous les pays d'Europe sans
exception ont adopté un principe simple
qui est le pluralisme doit être
reconnu nous avons C ou six grands
courants dans le
pays et ces grands courants là ils
doivent être représentés à la mesure du
soutien qu'il trouve dans l'opinion et
ça alors il y a plusieurs manières de le
faire mais il n'y a qu'un principe et un
principe qui est reconnu dans tous les
pays européens sans exception je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse l'écarter d'un
revers de main ou qu'on doiv l'écarter
d'un revers de main surtout quand vous
avez une loi qu'on appelle majoritaire
et qui fait une division de l'Assemblée
comme elle n'a jamais eu lieu vous
restez avec nous parce qu'on a beaucoup
d'autres sujets à vous soumettre et
notamment dans la story de Mohamed
[Musique]
boufs Françis baayron vous voulez vous
soumettre le cas de deux phénomènes de
la classe politique française qui
peut-être pensent qu'ils peuvent
révolutionner le monde et tout changer
imposer leur vue aux autres Jordan
bardellaa Gabriel àal oui aujourd'hui
dans un sondage hipsos pour le point
Gabriel àal devient pour la première
fois la personnalité politique préféré
des Français et pour l'Ifop et Paris
Match Jordan Bardella le président du RN
dépasse Marine Le Pen en terme de
popularité s'il y a un peu plus d'un an
les deux hommes défendaient leur chef
aujourd'hui il les dépassent dans les
sondages j'aimerais vous dire Monsieur
hatal que en vérité vous allez leur
infliger la double peine comment vous
financez votre système où vous dites aux
gens qu' peuvent partir plutôt nous ce
que nous proposons c'est un modèle qui
est juste c'est un modèle qui est
efficace vous vous ne l'expliquez pas
donc nous on explique on explique les
choses j'ai toujours pas compris vous
n'avez pas répondu à la question vous
n'avez toujours pas répondu à la
question je vous ai pas interrompu
Jordan B pas une seule fois il y a eu un
débat il y a de semaines je crois avec
deux candidats à la présidentiel sur ce
plateau tous les gens qui on regardaient
ont dit on comprenait rien parce qu'ils
arrêtent pas de s'interrompre peut-être
essayer de ça n pas le cas ce soir je
vous rassure ils sont partout les médias
se les arrach la une du nouvelops
challenge et L'Express pour Gabriel
hatal la semaine dernière la tribune du
dimanche pour Jordan Bardella qui est
devenu l'un des personnages politiques
les plus invités dans les matinales et
les émissions de télévision alors qui de
Jordan Bardella ou de Gabriel Atal
inspire le plus de confiance au français
est-ce que vous savez qui c'est c'est un
ministre celui de la de l'éducation
nationale oui Luis c'est Atal c'est un
ministre qui sert à rien bah Gabriel
hatal le ministre de l'éducation
nationale est-ce que vous savez qui est
ce jeune homme pas du tout Bardel pas du
tout c'est Jordan bardelin che qui pose
pour Marine je crois un truc comme ça
qu'est-ce qui vous inspire Gabriel à T
de la compétence ah non celui-là il
m'énerve d'accord c'est c'est
épidermique ah celui-là je l'adore
qu'est-ce qui vous inspire il a l'air
sympathique mais c'est tout je n'aime
pas du tout cet individu que du dégoût
je suis de toute façon d'accord avec lui
eff fiance totale à 34 ans pour Gabriel
Atal et 28 ans pour Jordan Bardella les
deux hommes sont déjà des maîtres de la
communication politique des animaux
médiatique qui est le plus éloquent le
plus punchliner et le plus difficile à
manœuvrer en interview réponse de ce qui
crois le fer avec ces deux créatures
politiques régulièrement je dirais
qu'ils ont tous les deux envie d'être
convaincants mais il y en a un des deux
qui est meilleur c'est Gabriel Atal ils
sont tous les deux éloquents peut-être
que Jordane Bardella a une forme
d'éloquence
plus brute de décoffrage Jordan Bardella
c'est des punchlin à chaque interview il
y en a 4 C je me rappelle que pendant la
campagne il avait dit les Français ont
le choix entre Emmanuel mckinse et
Marine le peuple et ça ça reste dans la
tête gabrielal quand on veut le faire
sortir de du message qu'il veut faire
passer c'est pas évident Jordan Bardella
tu vous laisse pas parler en fait peu
importe les questions que vous lui posez
il vient avec ses réponses j'utiliserai
le même mot pour les deux ambitieux
alors comment expliquer que ces deux
hommes inconnus avant 2017 se soit aussi
solidement installés dans le paysage
politique ceux qui sonent les Français
au fil des années nous ont répondu il y
a une évolution tendantielle de Jordan
bardela qui a tendance à progresser
notamment depuis les dernières élections
européennes où il a été tête de liste il
pourrait être quelqu'un de concret qui
dit des choses qui nomme les choses et
donc cette dynamique elle peut aussi se
poursuivre après barda les faiblesses
inhérentes à la marqueen il incarne un
parti qui reste controversé concernant
Gabriel Atal une évolution bien plus
rapide et plus subie notamment depuis
queil est ministre de l'éducation
nationale il plaît au français il
progresse parce qu'il va vite parce
qu'il est rentré dans ce ministère des
l'éducation nationale à travers la Bayas
qui a marqué les esprits pour Gabriel
Atal la mairie de Paris en 2026 semble
être un rêve trop petit certains le
voient déjà candidat à la présidentielle
en 2027 tout comme Jordan Bardella en
2032 à moins que cela ne se produise
avant alors une question qui est le plus
présidentiable entre le leader du
rassemblement national ou le petit
prince de la macronie le plus
présidentiable c'est peut-être bardellaa
ce qui est fascinant c'est que il commet
très peu d'erreurs pour son âge c'est
dingue et qu'il a l'air de connaître
tous les dossiers il y a du jeune Chirac
chez Bardella quand il y a un mélange de
Sarkozi et de Macron chez Gabriel Atal
Bardella c'est Le Pen qui s'appelle pas
Le Pen c'est son avantage et son
inconvénient si je puis dire j'ai un
petit problème avec cabrial tal je pense
qu'il est hyper doué mais il fait un peu
plus jeune que Bardella et je suis pas
sûr que les Français on envie encore
d'un président jeune Gabriel va encore
falloir qu'il fasse son trou qu' fasse
sa place quand Bard est là au fond il a
presque un boulevard derrière Marine Le
Pen un grand merci à Romain pido
Benjamin Delm et AUD pour organisation
de ces tournages et une question à Fr
oui franç pour vous qui est le plus
présentiable la question elle est assez
simple mais est-ce qu'ils sont prêts
déjà ces deux candidats qui sont issus
de la nouvelle génération vous avez
entendu Fran Olivier Gisbert qui a dit
quelque chose qui était intéressant qui
a dit le dans les temps qu'on vit
euh être plus jeune n'est pas forcément
un avantage ça vous a fait plaisir
d'entendre
ça non non parce que j'ai j'ai été à peu
près dans la position de ces de ces deux
garçons et je j'en garde un bon souvenir
mais alors perceer dans les sondages ne
vous étonne pas personnalité préférée
des Français plus populaire que Marine
Le Pen je vais vous dire quelque chose
qui surprendra personne à cette table là
euh il y a qu'une chose dont on soit sûr
dans les sondages c'est qu'il se trompe
h ou enfin ils ont été quand même élu
auss ils ont été élus c'est des
personnalités qui ont été élus que ils
ont un un attachement
mais attachement non ils ont pas été
élus à l'échelon national ils ont ils
ont été ils ont été élus à des mandats
et c'est très bien comme
ça ce renouvellement de génération est
constamment utile mais je ne crois pas
que ce soit sur le critère de l'âge
qu'un pays dans la crise profonde que
nous vivons va se décider je pense que
ce que nous vivons est euh très
profondément historique que c'est
quelque chose d'infiniment troublé dans
le cœur des gens
infiniment déplacé dans les relations de
pouvoir entre ceux qui sont au sommet et
ceux qui sont à la base et que c'est là
que la prochaine élection présidentielle
se jouera mais vous ne pensez pas que
ces deux hommes représentent aussi de la
fraîcheur pour les Français qui ont
peut-être aussi envie de tourner une
page avec certains hommes politiques oui
j'ai j'ai déjà vécu ça plusieurs fois
dans l'histoire récente y compris
récente du pays non je pense que qu'
sont doués l'un et l'autre inégalement
je pense que en tout cas Gabriel
Atal l'approche qu'il a des problèmes
d'éducation est intéressante pour les
gens après faut que ça entre dans la
réalité ce qui n'est pas si simple pour
avoir été presque 5 ans ministre de
l'Éducation j'ai une petite idée de ce
sujet merci beaucoup François Baou c'est
l'heure du 5/ 5 de Laurence
[Musique]
séchal par une décision historique oui
c'est le mot utilisé par le président
volodimir Zelenski président ukrainien
après l'ouverture officielle de
négociation d'adhésion de son pays à
l'Union européenne ça a été confirmé sur
un tweet tout à l'heure par Charles
Michel le président du Conseil européen
voyez a décidé d'ouvrir les négociations
d'adhésion avec l'Ukraine et avec la la
Moldavie volodimir zelensk qui est en
visite surprise en Allemagne et qui
s'est exprimé à a quelques heures
seulement thank you so
muchk you
soident
et c'est fait maintenant il a fallu pour
ça convaincre notamment le Premier
ministre hongrois Victor Orban qui est
un proche de Vladimir Poutine qui
s'opposa jusqu'ici à l'ouverture de ces
négociations hier il obtenait Victor
Orban le dégel de 10 milliards d'euros
de fonds européens et tout à l'heure il
s'est abstenu il a donc pas opposé son
veto comme il aurait pu le faire à
l'ouverture de de ces négociation pour
faire entrer l'Ukraine à l'Union dans
l'Union européenne les négociations
s'ouvrent seulement ça va prendre du
temps vous voyez il s'oppose quand même
par les mots Victor Orban en disant que
c'est une mauvaise décision François
baayrou ça va prendre des mois des
années avant que l'Ukraine ne rejoigne
l'Union européenne en quoi c'est une
décision historique tout de même ben
c'est une décision historique euh à
l'échelle de l'après-guerre euh c'est
une décision historique parce qu'elle
est une tentative
d'ajouter à l'Ukraine ou d'apporter à
l'Ukraine ce que les armes ne peuvent
pas lui apporter seul la vérité c'est
que on ne livre pas des armes à
l'Ukraine de manière à équilibrer
[Musique]
l'agression sans précédent depuis
Hitler que son pays connu et
l'héroïsme que les Ukrainiens
manifestent devant la
puissance militaire pour arrêter la
puissance
militaire russe euh et donc on essaie
d'apporter une autre arme qui est une
arme diplomatique qui est la
reconnaissance par l'Union européenne du
destin européen de l'Ukraine c'est de ça
dont il est question parce qu'il y a du
chemin il faut notamment en matière de
corruption que l'Ukraine ouis
enfin bon dans un pays qui est en train
de vivre ce qu'il vit euh dans un peuple
qui est en train de supporter ce qu'il
supporte avec euh les familles déchirées
tous ceux qui sont partis à l'étranger
et les jeunes hommes qui meurent euh je
pense pas que ce soit la corruption qui
soit le le qui soit le trait à à retenir
donc euh l'Union européenne a fait ce
qu'elle a pu pour ajouter un un poids
d'équilibre à ce
conflit qui dépasse évidemment les
incidents militaires habituels c'est
quelque
chose qui porte une
atteinte incroyable au principe qui a
fait la paix en Europe depuis la guerre
de 40 le principe qui a fait la paix en
Europe c'est le principe de
l'intangibilité des frontières on s'est
on a failli détruire l'Europe à cause de
cette question des frontières et là pour
une fois aon dit après la guerre de 40
après 45 on respectera les frontièrees
c'est ce principe que Poutine a attaqué
et c'est ce C cette attaque qui menace
aujourd'hui notre avenir en France on va
entendre l'appel déchirant de François
hardardi elle veut mourir François
hardardi elle dit qu'elle veut partir
bientôt et vite elle le fait savoir par
écrit à Paris Match et BFM parce qu'elle
ne peut plus parler elle la chanteuse de
comment te dire adieu Françoise hardardi
qui est malade elle criait déjà sa
volonté de choisir sa mort au téléphone
dans l'émission C'est àou il y a
quelques années quand on est contre soit
on est un
obscurantiste catholique ou autre soit
parce que on n'a pas d'empathie parce
qu'on a jamais rencontré dans dans sa
vie de personnes qui qui souffre et et
pour laquelle il n'y a rien à faire qu'à
abréger ses souffrances aujourd'hui elle
dit François hardardit il faut que le
président fasse de l'euthanasie une
possibilité le texte est prévu fin
février la première mouture je la cite
ouvre à la personne en fin de vie la
possibilité de bénéficier de
l'administration d'une substance létale
texte jugé approximatif trop permissif
par la société française
d'accompagnement et de soins palliatif
François Baayou comment est- comment
concilier l'appel de François hardardi
et tant d'autres Français et cette
réponse non la société française ai un
pointtif revendique que le développement
des soins palliatifs c'est aussi des
militants actifs contre l'aide à mourir
voilà il faut le dire c'est un lobbying
permanent on les entend à chaque fois en
réaction permanente sur toutes les
antennes à chaque fois qu'il est
question de la loi sur la fin de vie
sans dire qu'ils sont des militants
contre ses aides à mourir et évidemment
contre l'euthanasie donc je le précise
parce que ça n c'est rarement dit sur
les plateaux il faut le dire donc la
question comment conilier comment
concilier et bien je ça sera la deuxième
fois ce soir que je suis pas d'accord
avec Patrick en ce qui ce
qui ilé juste une
précision moi je considère que les
soignants qui
accompagnent mon meilleur ami est
morière donc je je je sais très bien de
quoi on parle les soignants qui
accompagnent ceux qui sont malades et si
gravement
atteints en les entourant de soins et en
les empêchant de souffrir pour moi ce
sont des héros c'est pas des militants
ce sont des héros je ne dis pas du tout
qu'il n'y ait pas de problème extrême
dans des gens qui pour des gens qui sont
dans situation extrême j'en
connais qui qui se trouve devant cette
nécessité là et on peut naturellement
les aider à s'endormir c'est ce qu'on
fait tous les jours la loi elle suffit
pour l'appliquer c'est ce que vous êtes
en train de dire ben euh nous avons fait
à peu près sur les soins palliatifs
1/ers du chemin à peu prs il y a une
difficulté d'accès au personne ne cont
qu'il y a un problème de soins P et donc
ce que dit le texte en préparation si je
suis bien informé c'est premièrement
attaquons-nous à la question des soins
palliatifs et de leur présence de leur
accès sur tout le territoire ce qui
aujourd'hui n'existe pas et c'est un
scandale un
SC c'est un scandale insupportable c'est
c'est ce qu'on fait tous les jours parce
que quand on endort les gens jusque au
bout et jusqu'au-delà du
bout c'est ce qu'on fait on sait très
bien que quand vous apportez des doses
de morphine très importantes ils vont
s'endormir et s'en aller et donc c'est
ce qu'on fait mais ça c'est la première
partie du texte et
é à l'administration d'une substance
létale avant qu'un patient soit quiment
inconscientis je ne suis opposé à rien
euh parce que je considère que c'est
tous les jours que ça se passe est-ce
qu'on peut mieux l'encadrer en regardant
la volonté et l'état de la maladie ce
que vous décrivez pour François hardardi
pour qui
j'ai une admiration qui qui qui ne
s'arrêtera pas ce que vous décrivez
c'est
qu c'est qu'elle est extrêmement c'est
qu'elle est extrêmement malade si elle
ne peut plus parler et donc je trouve
que que ces situations là sont
extrêmement
proches et et
je en tout cas si nous traitons des deux
sujets alors nous avons un texte qui me
semble-t-il sera plus humainement
équilibré l'église va faire de la
publicité à la télévision pour la toute
première fois de son histoire oui
l'Église de France se pe une campagne de
pub à la télé voici en exclusivité les
premières images accordz un peu de son
temps offrir son écoute s'engager et
tendre la main approfondir sa foi et la
mettre au service du vivre ensemble dans
un monde en perpétuelle quête de sens le
moindre geste prend toute sa valeur à
vous qui grâce à vos dons apporter la
fraternité et l'espérance dont nous
avons tous besoin un simple mot merci
l'Église ne vit que de don pour soutenir
toutes ces action sur le terrain donner
à
don.catholique.fr voilà cette campagne
de pub à partir de demain matin elle
sera sur C news et la semaine prochaine
sur BFM et LCI la Conférence des évêques
de France tente en fait d'enrayer un
déclin qui semble
inexorable on s'est rendu compte cette
année qu'on avait perdu plus de 50000
donateurs de 2021 à 2022 pour nous c'est
évidemment très problématique dans les
gens qui donnent il y a beaucoup de
personnes âgées voire très âgées et on
constate que de d'ancienne génération à
jeune génération la transmission de de
cet acte du don ne s'est fait pas
forcément le budget global de l'Église
de France c'est quasiment 600 millions
d'euros dont la moitié provient de Don
ce qu'on appelle le donniier du culte
d'où cette campagne donc qui commence
dès demain matin une prison évacuée à
cause d'inondation oui à sa en charante
maritime les pluis de ces derniers jours
ont fait déborder le fleuve les
habitants comme le mois dernier on sont
réduit à marcher sur des planches posées
sur des parpins en guise de de trottoir
ou carrément à sortir la barque et l'eau
menace maintenant la maison d'arrêt
sainte une prison vieille de 200 ans qui
a été entièrement évacuée 142 détenus
transférés vers autres établissements
elle est rendu nécessaire cette
opération par l'évolution de la crue de
la Charente qui a dépassé ses codes
d'alerte et qui devrait atteindre 5 M85
ce soir c'est un niveau de cru qui
risque d'empêcher les accès à la prison
donc il était nécessaire de réagir très
vite voilà évacuation préventive et les
inondations elles touchent aussi les
Alpes la vallée du Rône des villages de
lin ont été évacués volontairement noyé
pour protéger la ville de Lyon il y a un
gros sentiment d'injustice après qu'on
nonde pas une ville je veux bien mais
mais nous les personnes ici ils ont rien
demandé c'est toujours le même bordel on
protège liyon c'est compréhensible mais
ce qui me semble pas normal c'est que
les travau et les ennuis c'est les gens
du coin qui les ont alors ils en ont
marre ces gens parce que c'est la 4ème
fois en 6 ans qu'ils sont évacués en
fait il y a un événement qui explique
cette situation la photo qu'on voit là
c'est une photo de 1856 inondation à
Lyon à l'époque elle a entraîné une loi
signée par Napoléon I mais c'est de ça
qu' dont on parle aujourd'hui qui classe
toute une plaine du N en zone inondable
la bien nommé pleine du bouchage qui
compte aujourd'hui 10000 habitants sont
eux qui sont évacués régulièrement deux
bonnes nouvelles quand même d'abord
regardez il y a ce qu'on appelle une
patate anticyclonique c'est vraiment le
terme technique hein qui va sauver la
situation en raison de sa forme et tirée
pour ça que ça s'appelle comme ça elle
va s'installer sur la France ce weekend
faire cesser la pluie et puis l'autre
bonne nouvelle c'est cette cette carte
des nappes fréatiques elle est toute
fraîche elle vient de sortir et elle est
en bleu quasiment partout ça veut dire
que les nappes sont bien remplies
désormais c'est le cas de plus de la la
moitié de la France l'an dernier on
était qu'à 30 % seulement vous voyez
réagir là sur ces habitants qui sont
obligés d'évacuer pour protéger Lyon
mais je pense
que le génie de Napoléon II que vous
avez dit c'est qu'il a commencé partout
y
compris dans le village où je suis né
des travaux pour permettre que la vie
puisse s'établir sans avoir les
conséquences de ces événements
météorologiques et je suis per ad que
pour la plaine du bouchage il y a des
travaux de cet ordre à conduire vous
savez que Paris a été inondé en 1910 il
y avait 1,50 d'eau à l'Assemblée
nationale par exemple et qu'on a créé
des zones réservoirs de manière à
protéger la capitale ce travail il faut
le faire partout parce que je ne crois
pas que la nature toute seule s'en
charge ça c'est le commissaire le haut
commissaire au Plan qui
parle on a une minute pour parler de Can
et du prochain festival oui avec une
nouvelle présidente du jury elle
s'appelle gretaagwing on la connaît
réalisatrice de talent Lady Bird ou les
filles du docteur marche des films nommé
aux Oscars elle est surtout connue
dernièrement pour Barbie elle sait
diriger les acteurs regardez les les
images les vraies images du tournage de
Barbie
gretwin qui présidera le 77e festival de
Cann et c'est à VOUS d'ailleurs il sera
sur la Croisette en mai prochain en de
mot c'est un bon choix pierre Cho parce
que c'est la modernité et c'est en même
temps de talent c'est la plus jeune
depuis sopia Loren exement 66 et la
première réalisatrice américaine je
crois qui va diriger le festival de Cann
voilà ça commence au mois de mai on n
pas la date bon on l'aura
prochainement merci beaucoupou au
commissaire au Plan président du modèle
mes ma de poau dans un instant